une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
bienvenue aux sans filtre présenté par
caisse me le podcast on parle de ce
qu'ont vécu nos invités d'attitude ph
quentin avec moi baby de danse
[Musique]
caisse me vous le savez on en a déjà
parlé plante des arbres à chaque caisse
de cellulaires vendus en 2020 ont planté
plus de cent mille arbres et là ils
s'arrêtent pas là parce que pour la
prochaine année ils veulent planter
soixante mille arbres supplémentaires
c'est incroyable qu'à chaque fois que
vous achetez chez kiss me vous
contribuer à cet objectif
environnemental locke qui filtre les
émissions de carbone bien on le sait en
ce moment c'est important de penser
intelligemment quand on consomme fait
utiliser le code promo sf keynes pour 15
% de rabais sur les produits qu'ils me
puis remercié ou plus tard encore une
fois cette semaine au podcast grand
plaisir de recevoir lui la béquille pour
joie qui est musicien que vous
connaissez qui a gagné la voix qui fait
kiffer fait la musique qui sont des
albums qui va sortir un nouvel album
bientôt et qui on a parlé en fait de l
affaire qu'ils fissent vous savez de
patrick bourgeois qui était son père
bien sûr qui était un des membres des bd
qui nous occupe est beaucoup trop autour
on a parlé de sa relation en tête avec
son pack a manqué délai avec les
peut-être fin de trajet commun qui vit
ses émotions en fait ou plutôt commun
qu'il le vit pour ses émotions on a
parlé
de la création du prochain album de fred
st-gelais avec quiconque donnerait sur
le podcast avec qui il travaille sur ses
albums ne parlait un peu là la
différence ou de la deûle à la chicane
presque entre la gauche et la droite en
musée qui ont leur vous explique c'est
quoi ce sera une belle rencontre c'est
vraiment une mais ce doit être un coup
de galles bourgeois c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui
qui attend pourtant des monuments
qu'elle est en positif et en tout temps
le von finck ai
parlé un peu son nouveau projet de
construction d'une maison qui tend à
faire pour pour lui le sable en
construction la bd aussi à construire
d'un bébé qui s'en viennent bref super
conversation puis avant de vous laisser
l'écouté on va les remercier nous
commençons le podcast de cette semaine
et présenté par ravi cosmétiques c'est
une compagnie qui fait des produits pour
les soins pour la peau au québec si les
produits respectent l'environnement
respecte la santé humaine y pas de
produits toxiques là dedans et
évidemment c'est vegan parti au centre
et d'autres pas de casser quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur c'est vegan et
sans cruauté elle nous a envoyé une
panoplie de leurs gammes en fait produit
pour un homme parle moi des produits
qu'on dit ici là on a des produits
incroyables on ne savons
où sap est fourni
ils sont vraiment bons même des
shampoings en bas comme son cousin
d'acheter une bouteille qui est un gros
gros plus travis est vraiment eco
friendly lyon rangs de ceux à 15 on a lu
et la barbe lui là bas mot dans une
certaine époque que j'avais une grosse
barbe que je vais abandonner ce style
mais pour ceux qui portent encore la
barbe je la recommande plus la sent
tellement bon que je en train de
reconsidérer ma
on a eu deux crèmes pour la peau pour
l'éditeur une crème en moins qu'on vient
de connaître sans vraiment bon aussi
j'ai l'après rasage toutes sortes de
produits pour la peau les moyens d'
agence issue pour vous pour avoir une
peau une santé n'est plus des plus
optimales alors un code promo csf 15
vous allez sur les sites préavis points
6e et et vous allez avoir tous les
produits leur faites vous une petite
commande gotti vous ça fait du bien il
me semble vraiment bonne
remercie la gagne de près le podcast est
présenté par auch like bécane et ch
likes le fournisseur officiel des bières
et des spiritueux il dit prête à bord et
de tout ce qui se voit au studio sfr
toujours nos hanches lac derrière nous
et on s'emm ouvre souvent une lors les
podcasts et justement j'ai de m'ouvrir
les petites salles sur le dos des
malades voire émanant chaque
nouvelle sortie vient tout juste de
lancer est vraiment séparé moi j'ai
passé l'été à bord 17 ce et je suis pas
déçu d'abord cette nouvelle sorte le et
l'été n'est pas fini
[Musique]
ouais ouais
je préfère une ignoble hochelaga c'est
le seul établissement qui brasse ce qui
est une brasserie il distille en même
temps en fait qui brassent la bière et
les spiritueux et on les adore puis
hochelaga ils sont proches des valeurs
de l'entreprise en fait qu'ils sont la
communauté donc on a qu'à penser à l'or
non h la grc qui fait référence au
quartier dans lequel ses bras c'est
justement la créativité par leurs
nouveaux produits bien évidemment la
qualité des produits en plusieurs gammes
de bière unique qui ont laissé la
turquie sont vraiment une coche
au-dessus de 20 des serveurs sur le
marché on va se le dire le sas une
nouvelle mode push lag s'élève au dessus
de la mêlée sur celle de puis évidemment
on les adore parce qu'ils nous
encouragent ici au studio sfc des
partenaires de longue date donc la
prochaine peuvent passer
opep chacun pour une blague puis
remercié après oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui yaya qui hier à lui de l'église
a parlé des extras obligé les médecins
de
m entendre ta voix mais je posterai sais
que je t'aime tu devrais pas parler mais
sa route comme si pour vous entendre ta
voix parlée c'est la foi qui est la plus
basse a passé avec l'état photo fr le
podcast même si le numérique août -
mettant couderc mais au début c'était
l'enfer ouais je m'écoutais puis je
voulais m'arracher district est une
dictature au début du début de réécouter
tout et pas de quartier pour comme voix
basse et mettons les 20 premiers avis
vraiment dommage il est très écouté de
type pigeât pour voir si
il y avait la manie amené somme mais ça
m'a bien
amusé
mais tout s'est fait abattre car
quand on enregistre en paille se bricole
puis après à moi je
l'aï su je déteste ça sonne comme la
nouvelle affaire importante à force de 2
juste laisser les affaires vu par
elle-même puis de d'arrêter décide de
réécouter ou derichebourg ans parce
qu'on en fait trop on fait trop de
contenu ne m'amenez ce que je peux pas
contrôler quand tu te dis continu 24
heures sur 24 se rendrait malade puis
moi j'ai pas trop un créateur de
nouveaux créateurs de contenu le sujet
j'ai pas le réflexe même si j'aimerais
ça la voix mais je trouve qu'on en fait
trop c'est difficile de l'équipe iii
iv écoutait et 1,26 par n'y a plus qu'à
27 suffiront ville
mais cela est naturel après cela t on le
plus le temps on peut plus contrôler
notre image dans à 100% et essayer déjà
qu'ils n'assistent parfait parce que
pour répondre à cela moi je pense que la
meilleure façon de ne pas te tromper ou
de poser des niaiseries cédait 3 mai
ouais tu reste authentique ne peux pas
te tromper
un moment vraiment un combattant
mais je pense vraiment que c'est la clé
c'est vrai pareil qu'il faut que tu
fasses confiance à ta personnalité
python et d'intelligence à m'amener jeu
parce que moi je fais confiance à ce
groupe i à date ça fait au moins 36 36
moulage une carrière jacques et
s'arrêtera pas de casse tout supporter
mais moi je l'écouté
pas cru bon de chaume depuis toujours ne
joue aucun sens on avait 13 14 ans lui
et commence à faire de l'humour
mais on a une belle complicité de cépie
moi j'ai justement je pas interviewer
j'étais intéressé par les gens je peux
sont comme ça je s'intéresser puis
je réponds non de lui c'est la structure
c'est tout un concept c'est qu'avec les
cv on veut on veut avoir un d'histoire
derrière la personnalité
puis lui est vraiment structuré piquant
moi je m'appelle velléités place toutes
sauvées c'est cool pour soul parce qu'on
se complète marolati ses autres comme
concept l'espèce les entrevues t-il j'en
fais beaucoup d'entrevues plus en dehors
l'attendait à télé puis à radio on a
tout un son à 28 secondes pour parler de
quelque chose puis on a tout à quoi
avant ces quantités delà des entrevues à
télé ou radio c'est que quelque chose
que tu veux vendre puis ce qu'ils font
c'est d'abord l'histoire avant je
pensais pas de souci si je sais pas
je ne sais pas marc du prix il ya
travaillé comme serveur dans un
restaurant chinois mais peut-être que
quelqu'un qui quitte riquiqui serveurs
en ce moment qui se dit moi je vais te
chante en tabarouette mon chanteur
préféré il ya vraiment un job que moi
comment ça se
passe et c'est sallie sénile tout le
monde
ça commence ici des mois puis cresson et
des jobs et pouvant atteindre moi je
sais quoi que sur ton cv mettons le cas
moi j'ai tellement fait d'affaires je
traîne en vente je travaillais en
construction je vais mettre du jeu
réside pavie unis même si j'ai eu une
cliente piste est ma mère j'avais comme
13 affiches et je
reste engagé pour et j'ai touché à pas
mal de domaines sujet tandis que moyenne
à tout mais tout ce prix mettons la
voile oh oui mais en parallèle à la voie
tu vois j'ai acheté des chambres un
dealer de chant
à l'école d'administration puis j'écoute
ça va tout est bon mais si aujourd'hui
j'ai plus un peu tout fait maison mais
le ch capable de comprendre le barca
c'est ce qui est pratique mais en même
temps il rien quel jeune elle à 100% ça
s'est fait
à
chanter
mais
ça n'est pas pour qui tu es je prends un
grand chanteur jusque chez orange les
masses et justice pis et ça impressionne
le monde c'est la panade avoir dit que
c'était comme mon but c'est de montrer
mon arrange parce que c'était là c'est
tellement bon on a la qualité jouer sur
ces forces fois ci se joue et m'efforce
mais
technicien
sait juste que chine et avec un organe
qui tique telle farce au pis c'est tout
peut-on en faire
[Rires]
la justice autre chose vitré soi même si
c'est de la pratique et ça fait 12 ans
je fais de la musique et j'ai fait des
concours avec mon band
avec murray mais myriam qui tapait sur
des heures et les cymbales kiejman en
dépôt fait que j'ai fait la ron la walk
of shame à 20 les gars du coin c'est ce
gîte ou non mais c'est vrai le souvent
l'on parle du mollet jeune tu t'en sors
pas si loin
zeng est on appelait ça la mort comme
chez
toi il te laissais aller planter
mon père mais je dis que tu fasses
semaines maintenant la qui avait connu
le sont pas et que voit le plein de
contacts si tu fasses qu'un mail qui y
appelle kipré femmes saisissent pas bon
ça va faire quoi exactement c'est un
autre une illusion d'optique les gens
qui s'y colle ma phobie même que des
strikes plus dans kaboul c'est un
couteau à double tranchant c'est qu'une
étiquette leur exploit gagner ticket lui
même moi j'ai une étiquette et puis
coach et j'ai six numéros radio le
premier tour magne et qu'est-ce que je
fasse de plus 1 g puis quoi faire de
plus pire mais ça ne dérange pas je
pense que si tu aimes brésil le renie
poubelles et jets y trouve ça na waie
puis après si tu fais pour ceux qui
aiment ce pays ce qui fait de la musique
pour plaire à tout le monde je fais de
la musique pour plaire aux gens qui même
après sociale agricole et viticole et
c'est tout le temps la question de ces
ya tellement de
possibilité de consommer de l'ordre des
trucs verra si ça te rejoins peu et tout
le peuple ferme d'ailleurs complètement
c'est vrai on oublie souvent comme soit
la société actuelle de commence dès
qu'on est tout à droite parole ouais
c'est ça mais mais comme si ça plaît pas
écoute le
faire c'est d'écouter grille j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus polémique en
citant un être humain area tic c'est un
être humain qui fait des choix tu
m'entends tu vaux oui j'ai eu le [ __ ]
de choix 2.8 marque des biscuits ouais
je parle pas de super bowl il ya même
pas une seconde après tout est-ce que
t'adresse le feq thème parce que je
prends tes préférences sur la page et je
n'aime pas
c'est maylis value sur sa page web
j'aime pas ta musique j'aime pas comment
tu t'habilles
mais je m'étais y aider les artistes qui
ont su plus d'offres que moi natation
j'ai quand même choisi le dans je veux
pas que j'espère que je fais l'unanimité
la mets dans mon manque et naulleau si
c'est plus populaires ses potes et
polarisant donnant des gros et aux
images in
pieces parce que j'ai pas bientôt dans
la vie non plus j'ai les mêmes amis
depuis vingt ans la même blonde depuis
12 ans ma vie est assez tranquille c'est
ça que j'ai donc pas besoin de rodez est
une fois passé mais ça me dérange pas
besoin de faire de faire réagir j'allume
mon spot le cas je fais des choses les
restes du thème plus
contre la maison je le bats pas tu avais
pas pas vrai c'est c'est ainsi que sur
la glace a autrefois c'est ainsi quand
même vote
pour quelqu'un d'avoir des relations de
vraiment longue date - encore le moins
mettons que ce soit des amis ou des
partenaires invités de quand tu
rencontres quelqu'un qui à 0 ami de
longue date oui approché par guy sur le
monde qui viendra contrer plus et ses
amis vraiment approche mais comment cela
se passe t
il si ce béton moitié maintenant une
faille rentrer dans ma vie maintenant le
puits à votre rencontre et dans le
premier deux semaines max puis mettons
qu'il rencontre quelqu'un pendant le
premier mois - demi tu rencontres
personnes de son entourage qu'il ya
peut-être quelque chose le parle d' amis
potentiels météo jamais rencontré tu dis
non non c'est mais j'étais correct
piercing au racing je sais pas pour moi
le lev ci aider afin que la check list
d'importants
moyens j'oublie le moule mais quand tu
peux faire confiance au moment où et
quand et amicale de baky
c'est quand tu peux quand un groupe
proche de toi qui s'est fait longtemps
qu'ils le savent a dit que j'étais
tobback stade petro fait chier
à ses seuls loyauté chercher pour moi
ces gens reine des appareils plus
important mais met au travail avec mon
band avec les jets que je travaille la
loyauté c'est juste moi si c'est
primordial lévy dans toutes les
relations c'est la royale
c'est là
que la
[Rires]
loi met au travail
dans des bennes aussi ça va des 200 cm
cim est aussi tombé ça que sont
interchangeables puis que le titre a
peut-être changé de gros morceau en
scène vont moins s'investir dans projet
jirau moins sentir très peu fait que les
autres tough leur loyauté mais toi aussi
tu t'engages de qui met ces tests avec
moi tu avais moins pour la boîte seppi
ça fait qu'il ya une confiance mutuelle
tpiy ça fait que le band même plus à
part elle s'apparent ait dimanche matin
à chaud sont par la musique le samarien
ben qui sont venues
pique était si je dis tu donnes pas la
bulle de caen pour un show musique donne
un show ouais mais c'était tout seul
parce que c'est un nom que celle du
caire qui dunke c'est dans un show piles
et les cinq autres narnia ils
s'arrêteront pas d'écrit c'est un peu
plate et
puis moi je dis que tant que
c'est mon nom mais c'est nous c'est nous
qui donne les choses et on le fait
ensemble c'est ok pour ça c'est
important il ya quelque chose de l'autre
aussi dans l'idée d'un banc de thons on
pense maintenant c'est moi je joue un
peu de musique le lundi devant mais
c'est l'idée de faire j'aurais on se
fait un pen à sa fille comme d'abord un
bain donc le nom qui sont non si c'est
ton nom au bâti ou ariane dans ton cas
c'est le nom qui est un robin pas grave
c'est le nom d'hubert de travaux ça va
guérir ans en grèce il ya quelque chose
de vote quand même c'est ici que moi
aussi une image qu'on genre d'image
poétique on qu'on se fait le tenue du
band baisse comme une fraternité moi je
suis je compare ça au moins j'ai joué
pas mal en pis et quand je dois tourner
le si c'est comme une équipe danoise un
tournoi
on fait de la musique
ségo aussi 80 artistes piqué de
l'artiste partage son club et son solo
tout le monde sont présentés petite
fille qui maquille coup le tissu pour
juste comme soliste elle dit
c'était juste un autre type de chaume et
émettons santé kendrick sur les plaines
que tu avais genre kendrick tu avais
dans les bennes caché dans le fond qui
est pratiquement cacher le type s'était
même pas
social il ya eu tout un
cérémonial
se situe league ligue est allé voir
l'hippodrome
5000 personnes là puis arrive juste à
tout ça commence à jouer ça sonne big
12 ce qui est fou
[Rires]
c'est comme la 4e membres de muse le
sait mieux s'en est bien jouer comme ça
on retrouve ça sonne dans ma carrière
parce que lui comme l'apport des foules
fait que les genres système mais genre
caché en arrière les joueurs du sine la
baisse est celui qui biffe tout l'art
mais les blagues il ya plein d'exemples
dans le fond mais les blacks qui tient
au fait ça l'était vous avez vu
peut-être cette saison c'est un duo
guitare
il ya de la baisse biais d'autres
instruments des fois le cpie ya deux
groupes se succèdent ici mais j'espère
que les
deux pourquoi
pas su que le monde enfin comme elle le
chef bloquiste est bon mais le betis le
qui joua crissement à bien arc
on maudit studio leçon 4
non je comprends pas chacun
j'ai fait des guides des comédies
musicales j'aurais autant saint denis le
moment même une petite pièce
on était en dessous des caches en
dessous type on arrivait enfin nos
instruments france à lui plus loin
disait c'est qu'ils se battaient pour
une drague walter benn
traque s'est encastré annoncé
l'ambassadeur de la jo gomis et puis
c'est ce qu'on veut mais ouais c'est un
gâchis comprends pas ouais ouais moi
fait de la question c'est sorti
comme si les saints n'était pas assez
gros sous mais j'avoue que cette loi
était était une scène par exemple celle
là c'en était trop et est rempli les
gens les décors ils ont l'habitude at il
y avait une pythie son full danseurs
comédiens peut-être pour toutes sortes
de raisons mettez moi mettons de mon
point de vue de musiciens je pense quand
même que tu me plus value que tu vois et
des musicologues wipikit face aux quais
la musique que j'entends il est là ils
jouent vos vrais artistes pour juste moi
je pense que ça serait mieux mais il ya
eu du monde dans l'organisation qui ont
décidé autrement pigeon expression
labeur l'argent et qui veulent que ça
sonne la chason beef que mais ils
veulent pouvoir le bloquer dans 60 ans
j'ai
[Rires]
aussi que comme comme si la seule tête
de la vie possible il
faut être avant la voix mettons le ctu
clair tous les formats musicaux ce n'est
pas que
moi j'ai commencé à faire de la musique
a peut-être certains avec un acte mon
band je t'aime khaled ben en fait ça
c'est fait c'est quoi le nom pour
s'appeler hyundai faisait des compos en
anglais très
applaudi un peu
puis on était ensemble pendant quand
même huit ans
chaque mois à 20 avant la voix dans le
fond j'ai fait ça mais je commençais à
17 ans fait que
ça a été un processus dans le fond mais
match homme qui était le drama le stub
anglais le chanteur ray parti où l'on
met dehors je me rappelle pas cet éco
d'histoire
puis sont passés par internet mon père
puis le lui monte au medical enir ça m'a
sûrement pas comme deux gouttes d'eau il
doit avoir la même voie d'eau chaude
c'est sur moi je n'ai jamais chanté de
ma ville ont pillé mené et mène ce
marché des outils
comme ans est un peu rondes et sananès
nana pièce où conduit à un médecin
j'achète donc le von goethe également
d'acheter j'étais rendu un peu moi qui
j'ai chanté puis c'était comme les gars
capoter pas pensé à ce moment là j'ai
pris des échos chanter dessus pour toi
avant 6 août sa non jamais je ne
dirai pas que c'est bon
c'est bon il faut que
900 pièces est comme ça ça commençait
pas que c'est à cause de ce bâti grâce à
mon ami qui est qui me met forcément
sous les 6
d'abord les coupes tout véritable musée
où
j'étais pas d'accord
j'ai pris des coups après j'ai j'avais
une professeure de chant qui a là des
dunes d'écault aussi une chanteuse au
père aupiais
moi je n'arrivais plus de monde m'a dit
que j'étais un bon défi
j'avais
à mac os et appartements à mettre tout
et non quelle image mais c'était positif
le tir elle savait que j'avais le talent
à voulais juste que j'arrête de me
trouver bondues puis pendant trois ans
j'ai pris des cours avec ça a tout
changé à partir de ce moment là j'ai
commencé disposant de bien chanter mais
si cd4 d'affaires de ce genre de choses
tu vois ça
peut pas forcer tout croche l'exergue la
route blessés sont ainsi livrés man 2 le
site de l'opération puis six mois
convalescence c'est de la merde c'est
aujourd'hui je peux faire 5 chaude en
semaine mais capable c'est fini ça m'a
vraiment aidé
puis quand tu étais petit est ce que
maintenant tu entendais ton père
chantait souvent ou potins pas vraiment
parce que machine à 93 m'ont pas les
bébés ça durait 89 et 95 puis
les deux
anciens puis comme vraiment arrêter de
faire la musique il était comme et que
ce qui m'a dit le ses qualités et
écuries du showbiz cette salle devrait
naître au pit est un type sait pas
écrire et de la musique et ne peut pas
continuer à écrire pour du monde il y
avait le studio on est toujours eu un
studio dans le sol à un drame des
plaines guide ses pieds fac mais je me
suis jamais vraiment intéressé à sopi
lui il était comme vraiment gaz et au
delà du milieu puis la musique fakih a
décidé d'arrêter puis recommencez gens
en 2008 bien 2008 le mois j'avais 15 ans
15-16 un pee wees m'a foutu la musique
ce moment à l'autre si les deux ans
après que j'ai là j'ai commencé à aimer
ça pis le jsk comme coraline c'est
vraiment pas il faisait son avis comme
tous savaient mais c'est important et
c'est comme plus sûrs mais
il y avait d'autres projets déjà
il ya eu plein jobs way c'est un moment
un peu plus plus dark l'hôtel c'était
moins c'était moins glam mais tant que
c'est son side-car appui moby ma grande
soeur noah comme un peu grandi la dette
s'est fait que
rapidement on savait pas si on
comprenait pas ce que le monde
de quoi c'est chavez ce qui est sûrement
moins que le réaliser ou s'était fait
tout le temps été un peu loose un peu ça
toujours être un peu le coin ça qui est
pas une fois que je fait comme ahmed
s'est plus récemment breton depuis les
cinq dernières années
quand on fait fait un come back aux
francofolies de montréal ça faisait
comme quinze n'avaient pas joué ensemble
puis il ya eu jean cent mille personnes
s'étaient retrouvées lundi en 2008
c'était la folie furieuse dans les pilot
moi je t'ai lunch d'accord au moins
des pancartes patrick je suis ton fils
tu as quand même fois qu'ils aient moins
[Rires]
fréquemment j'ai capoté mais après cela
j'ai commencé moi j'avais même année
j'ai commencé à faire des shows avec lui
parce qu'on a eu on a fait un album duos
à
100% parce qu on avait
mon timing est vraiment pas clair mais
en 2014 il le producteur la poule aux
oeufs d'or gala conduit à tva et elle
dit
patrick puy le devis que voulez vous
faire un tour sans eau chaude à la can
je suis
la pelouse de l'as monaco ouais ok pas
qu'on ait fait ça bien parti à ce
moment-là ça vraiment panier puis on est
plein de demandes de spectacles puis il
y avait cinq à sept qu'andrée watters
qui était sur ce show l'opinion il
partait en tournée avec des artistes
invités les terres et prés puis on était
sur leur tournée fait que j'ai commencé
à faire la ligue des gros festivals au
québec avait à partir de de ce show télé
là on a fait un album duo puis à partir
de 2015 j'ai commencé à faire leur show
des bébés je me disais comment tu fais
une coupe de tourner sur leur show
lettonie bds a commencé comme sortis de
notre honneur notre jean de daye de
collaboration musicale mais sinon on va
le faisait des trucs de mon bord puis
j'ai même pas à mon prochain challenge à
la belgique aa1
aux quelque chose pour moi
car c'est comme ça ça commence vraiment
si c'est ça c'est en boîte et un an
après à l'ordre mais sur le
site comme outil de vue d'un stage avant
cette période de l'avent qui raflent
awak'it la merde
mon ex a fait la voix à 2015 qu'est qui
a s'est rendu en quarts de finale qu'est
d'un quart de finale il y avait trois
filles avaient elles liana il y avait
dominique fils aimé puis avait une fille
s'appelait gaye puis un festival l'été
d'après cette édition le qui dit moi je
veux c'est trop fait la même chose
faite
ok qu'il ya dans le fond là soit restée
de mixer mai liana les bébés qui gagnait
après
le rappel c'est le festival dans rue le
rsa dans la rue que d'art marne à perdre
deux femmes dans les arts dix mille
personnes sont annoncées chiant
incroyable c'est pour moi la plus grande
foule devant laquelle j'ai joué c'est
tout chaud avec câble ont exécuté
laquelle rihanna rihanna qui est
pile sept heures on capote est quand on
demande à pression après les autres
monsieur d'abord vu le
fils à l'autre la barbe de tout cela
c'est cool d'après ce genre je pense une
ou deux ans mais après tu étais
fait que c'est ça notre jeunesse qui a
partagé
ses fous pareils qu'est ce que tu disais
que
j'avais pas trop si je le savais ce que
m'ont pas rapide mais en même temps ça
reste on compare
le matin bref c'est ça
avec avec julie bélanger l'a fait
mélangez mal comme il se réveille le
matin et le pis c'est moins précise
daniel bélanger c'est mon père c'est
papa le genre et rêver mieux le
way perspective face et moi surtout le
moi j'ai deux soeurs puis c'est moche
comme le la portant de drapeaux les
bourgeois les bébés
moi je m'en fait si je mens fait par les
basses et satin a reçus
mais ça dépend ben moi je viens sur cinq
se le dise
ça me dérange pas parce que justement je
l'accepté je suis fier d'être soutien
parce que mine de rien dit s'il ya des
billets plein d' hitler c'est comme je
suis moi qui peut jouer l'unité mais
wifaq c'est comme si j'ai hérité de ses
tantes et puis mais quand même quand
deux albums et
4 2 albums des grilles du site en plus
c'est vraiment foot et c'est fou puis
j'ai quand même j'ai comme hérité de son
rôle de son fan bei souci fakher mois ci
c'est vraiment là de 7 à 77 ans et
richard deal mais c'est vraiment à ce
type il y en a de tous les orges puis
dans mon show je m'arrange pour faire
plaisir à tout le monde c'est bien je
vais pas le show très chaud pour les
gens viennent d'abord puis j'aime faire
plaisir au monde et puis je fais des
tournées benamor chaud puis ça ça marche
ça pas de sens et c'est sur ces
gigantesques et des caisses de tonnes
cette idée me progressé c'est l'écriture
de chansons peuple haïtien croyants
c'est un maître de la mélodie
mais si sûr avec son enfant et c'est moi
j'écris mes chansons je collabore avec
pleinement je les ai reçus frais d'ici
là bas avec fred souvent été pillés
c'est quand même
fou tu m'étonnes niçois mais ladite loi
jouer
mais je me présente vraiment pas avoir
le même talent que lui avait mais je
pense que ça va mais j'essaye de recrue
des jets de faire des trucs qui me
ressemblent ces petites écoute mais
toute écoute les toubibs il laisse pas
partie sinon nous avons été complètement
différent mais ça se marie bien
maintenant un vrai jeu de couleurs sud
l'autre le le suit et sur la table ne
souhait pas vraiment à vendre mais
c'est vraiment eu des fous et partage
des vidéos genre de lui qui qui joue
métier genres des styles font exprès
c'est c'est parti d'un condo reçus nous
parlait je demande son background de
comme échoué dès lors
cette école maintenant les chouettes je
laisse en fait
c'est bon
c'est
bon c'est écoutez c'est layton qui fait
c'est bien
c'est pas du choix de
m
c'est des gros riffs
c'est vrai c'est vraiment pas elle sait
juste que c'est du gaultier évanescence
le site est pas à ses débuts
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya encore de la
grosse guide dans tout le titre on était
comme est encore pendant l'époque
l'époque pop punk ça il y avait des
trucs nu metal ou s'il attend la
naissance radio jean renkin prague
jouait le haut c'est ça la concerne est
des genres
mais c'est sa fac et en catégorie
souvent le monde c'est carey je pense
anciens on est à bout de fesse mais
parce qu'offrir c'est vraiment il ya un
pays métal dirai pas de sens
le fax et comme du gros métal avec 17 km
chouette 10 des actions de gm qui joue
la ghetto c'est comme un dieu puis c'est
mélodique au bout de ces vraiment ça
flashe
mois encore depuis que je les ai
rencontrés deux fois j'ai des questions
sur des affaires tpiy georges sens que
je peux y écrira le temps de me répondit
gentille vraiment il est vrai est
vraiment piste est vraiment devrait
compter aussi comment ça s'était fait
qui avait réalisé son premier album
c'était quand même c'est quand même tout
change en fait le tellier il était comme
dans une passe ou ce qu'ils voulaient
rien savoir de la musique le puits déjà
dans sa ville à l'ouest et jean fauque
des musiques de ma vie n'était pourtant
pas que les services réalise l'album à
mon fils c'est pas toi qui t'es malade
mais pendant qu'on faisait l'album si le
moment paraît plus en plus confuse et
l'album il lui dit si tu sais puis
travailler moins payent témoin qui
s'était comme connaissent pas s'y est
révélé
pourquoi tu travailles pas plus et puis
pourquoi t'en donne pas plus tu
t'impliques et puis c'est fred
finalement qui réalise tout pillé moi
qui est en studio du pain mais là on se
dit mon frère et moi c'est peut-être là
dernier projet qui va
comme un gant on lui pardonne et il
travaille pas trop et finalement 3e
après
ouais parce qu'au départ lui était comme
un peu cow coréenne décorée à l'est de
royal ali faisant 106 est calme à fred
qui le taux de faible parce que mon père
travailler
mais on savait pas les autres pourquoi
on faisait
jusqu'à la fin mon père me disait
qu'elle n'est pas mauvais
mais je croyais le croyait
simon pegg c'était un goût quand même
violent et suive les paladins faible
jusqu'à la fin et digestive clément v
surpris quand je sortais
utilité rang du groupe my man of steel
group était couché dans son allié et 10
membres ont capoté six caravanes vont me
voir mal vu sortir un disque
ok mais jusqu'à
quand
quand il décide et nous nous sommes à
mon masseur puis ma mère ma tante on
était parti en chine le 23 novembre qui
est moins de 26 puis on s'est dit on par
douze jours à ce combat ou en reste ni l
huile de provence puis finalement trois
jours après ils m'ont de ce qui vous
attend menu tu dois
faire
des escales pisi mamac matin sont restés
pour m'asseoir on est parti plus tôt
mais jean 40 ans de vol en avion à huit
avions à prendre
et on était sur une croisière sur le lay
la rivière puis c'est quoi le méjean la
plus longue que
les ninjas je sais pas mais je peux
écouter sans arrêt de jeu les juifs
étrangers à compter sur le bateau quand
je lis eu
le temps d'arriver n ville latent qui
avait emprunté un avion là qu'on arrive
à pékin montreal le stepper pic à
montréal c'était pékin détroit d'être
noir avec siemens a pris 36 ans
mais j'avais rien ce mensuel puis je
savais que quand j'allais atterrir à
montréal non c'est la halle est
explosive c'est
bête
comme tu arrivé
j'ai passé ça s'est fait j'ai quand
j'arrivais même moi ça faisait quand
même trois quatre jours attend que ça
m'avait fait que
c'est
automatique quatre jours après j'étais
avec la voix junior au sein de vidéotron
puis je faisais simon cette boutique je
faisais un medley des bébés au centre d
autres honda 20 et même personne mais
c'est fait c'est davantage tabucchi puis
on faisait ce une semaine après mon père
est mon puis elle et moi
j'ai dit oui c'est sûr je le fais m
quand j'ai commencé l'étude de la monde
ça braille et est juste moi qui étais de
glace 1 faisait hier la famille et ont
tissé jusqu'au botté tu veux tu
fais tu sortes ta vie en général met on
a juste aller de l'avant tout le temps
ben ouais ouais quelque chose que tout
le temps en fait moi
j'aime pas ça mais j'aime post a feeling
c'est le feeling des tristes le p-dg
d'edf
si nous avons déjà une puce puis c'est
sûrement pas bon départ mais comme on le
dit un jour soit rattraper un jour ça
vaut peut-être pour moi c'est ça ça
dépendrait de nom mé il y avait pas d
fois que c'est plus difficile mais je
suis vraiment déjà pas du genre à
amorphe et je déteste le sentiment qui
m'aime et je me mets pas dans ces
situations le genre avec ma blonde vous
l'écoutez dc os c'est l'émission qui
fokine triste j'écoutais 20 secondes ça
commençait à monter j'ai fait comme j'ai
pas envie d j'ai pas envie de
j'ai décidé de police
j'écoutais un podcast puis c'était deux
humoristes mais non qui dit genre
justement exactement ce que tu viens de
dire le sait comme je vais jamais écouté
tout filtrer ce nom genre c'est un
sentiment qui me fait de la peine qu'il
aime profondément papilles du monde qui
veulent écouter des films qui font
pleurer
complètement cessé sûrement parce que je
pars à l'aise avec ce sentiment parce
que c'est ça aussi mais je dis je fais
des tonnes de la clé fois de mon papier
en amont chaud il ya une place le cbb ni
moi même ni
puis moi je sais comme si ça passe à
côté
c'est peut-être pour ça coûtait 15
sièges mais toi tu sais mettons
tdu proche de tes sentiments quant à 0 0
à lens 0 ouais faict puis sacré dessus
des problèmes dans des relations des
fois ça fait 12 ans chaque meuble en
juillet le moral ça va moins bien
connais tu
mets ton dans les relations même au delà
de juste une relation amoureuse je sais
pas si j'ai jamais été autrement moins
que c'est dû à 10 c je pense qu'il y en
a toute une façon d'éviter nos lyonnais
qui sont kitty qui sont ces émotions
lopy en ville moi je veux juste pas si
c'est vraiment à cinq domaines 6 nuls
mais puis je fais de la musique tichy
j'essaie des créatifs plus tôt dans la
vie tu effectif vraiment deux opposés
dans la pression que tu accumules
d'affaires guerre des trucs en dedans tu
clé ça devient lourd tout en postant que
non
c'est comme si un petit tiroir fermé à
clé pis les clichés php ou la clique
puis est-ce que met-on quand quand écrit
des textes quand tu fais ta musique est
ce que si tu 5 km en dans ce tu mettes
7,6 et c'est ce qui rend ce terroir
j'ai écouté je ne sais pas c'est comme
si j'ai de la misère à me comprendre
moi-même mais si c'est vraiment une
affaire qui est qui est difficile pour
moi j'ai de la misère à gg benza à
m'exprimer est sûre s'il a fallu que
j'essaie de j'essaie de comprendre
maintenant que 6 et je sais pas que
c'est pourquoi ça se passe comme ça puis
comme je lé extériorise l'artiste
j'imagine que ce que tu veux dire c'est
que je pourrais peut-être l'extérieur en
chansons mais je pense pour qui la
patate et dans le fond on le sait
peut-être que ce qui me peut être que
les choses ça m'aide aussi à à libérer
la sérotonine
certaines séries tonnes de bombes sur un
chemin
sachez que c'était péril de ma ville ça
a été comme ça s'est passé
le montre de tout de même pas comprendre
mais
dans deux semaines ou un mois après je
partais à tourner pour mon premier album
après la voix n'avait je sens quelque
chose si je travaillais tout un tout les
jours je travaillais tout le monde
[Rires]
et être capable de voir comment ton
processus de deuil c'est fait ou pas
vraiment aimé ton qu'il avais tu déjà
fait un peu d'argent pas vraiment quand
j'ai des réflexes
qu'est ce que je pense c'est juste pas
fait je pense que c'est ça prend plus
catchy personne même là c'est ternel tu
veux quand même je pense jusqu'à jusqu'à
la fin de ses jours quand tu seras
jamais
[Musique]
ça c'est moi le ph du futur loin il ya
beaucoup de choses à gérer ben je parle
souvent parce que quand même temps je
suis ta veille de prendre une décision
souvent souvent sauvages mais je pense à
lui je dis est ce que je veux vraiment
le cedar manon et souvent c'est quoi
c'est itunes en a marre de
50 50 50 50 pour ça mes décisions c'est
pour lui faire plaisir 50 c'est comme un
tabouret mois
mais ouais
je pense que ça fait juste prendre plus
de temps mais c'est quand même n'importe
quoi
mais attends c'est un deuil la pandémie
le pauvre est ta job c'en était un un
deuil mais n'ont jamais fait makina qui
le font pas c'est un deuil mettant leur
succès le pit et je sais que manet
je vais moins rouler glottis mais ça va
être un des moments
forts et je tiens justement qu'est-ce
que melle reiss
de belleville
et j'aime mieux que lui j'aime pas mieux
plus décède mais si j'ai à choisir entre
lui ou un enfant mais lui il
ya eu plein d'affaires cas personne va
vivre dans sa vie n'est acquis puis même
lui le dise il sera cueilli pas passer à
côté de grand chose c'est ce qui passe à
côté de ses petits-enfants les autres
partis des listes c'est plate mais
il ya quelque chose là dedans quand même
qui est de se dire
on parlait avec adib alkhalidey sur le
podcast qui disait que
c'est qu'il faisait remarquer qu'on
passe juste une fois dans vimont et puis
c'est vrai que prendre un est longtemps
pour être triste mettons en oeuvre qui
nous permet de profiter du moment qu'on
parle sur le tir et outils de justement
le ceto c'est comme les affaires
commencent à lever
mon père décède pilote g100 show qui
s'en viennent phi phi c'est une partie
importante de terrain qui voisin qui
peut être vraiment trippant 6 et pas
teintée de tristesse en a le temps de
morosité
c'est genre d'expérience que tu veux
vivre pleinement pis il ya pas sûr que
puissance lotis dans ce que laisse
évidemment c'est le deuil de ton passe
quand même yo je me dis souvent on
omet du négatif dans nos vies qui est
pas mal moins
importants puis marc herremans que le
décès de son père
pas mal de temps quesnoy d'evry 35 toi
ayed a fight mafiques bien plus d'anti
mettons d'amis l'amendé tout dit le pic
est ce que ces paliers un deuil ce que
tu dis que tu dis le moi je voulais
vraiment ça parce que je trouve que dans
ville tu le bonheur le sni question
perspectives moins une question de
comment que toutefois la situation c'est
qui s'étoffe le tout est de bonne humeur
ce qu'il ya c'est fatigant l'un des fois
puis je m'occupe amendement le vraiment
à fond ma blonde après confirmer ça mais
c'est vraiment une question de
perspective aujourd'hui on est mort dit
innovants et demi 10 heures on ne
ressent pas de castille
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une question de
perspective puis de trouver ta
perspectives à chaque fois c'est comme
toujours parfaite le traîneau situation
mais l'om est ici ses possibilités je
sais pas moi j'essaie de le vaud à
moitié plein ben oui mais c'est clair
c'est clair on a rencontré geneviève
everell york qui la propriétaire
fondatrice de souchez à la maison
d'accueil puis elle a le vécu une enfant
un enfant selon une annonce un enfant un
enfant une enfance l'enfance non sans
parfois terribles c'est sa mère était
toxicomane son père était alcoolique ça
m'a requinqué
c est assez rare s'y retrouver un schéma
se faisait battre l alleud elle habitait
dans un krach avec sa mère du cpie
jamais dans tout ce assez plein de son
sang il a devant nous genre ultra
heureuse à 12 h je suis tellement bien
placé comme acquis ma question de
perspective en classe parce que alors eu
toutes les prises de son bord de la baie
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment de la
façon du prêt à faire puis aussi j'ai
réalisé le budget it est
de plus en plus de réaliser enfin je
rencontre plein de montres pathétique
c'est un peu plus philosophique dit
avant je n'aurais jamais pensé comme
sauter moi je comme j'attaque parents à
beaupuy je fais juste pensé mais des
fois faut que tu apprécies tu es puis
quand j'étais jeune je voulais faire de
la musique internationale cepii tout et
j'aime la sorte un jour mais si ces gens
là il pense quand même à côté de pleine
affaire incroyable que nous on a la
chance de vie on a la chance de faire un
puits pour ce que tout est une question
de perspective puis c'est supprimer mais
j'ai fait un peu de casse et qui est
guillaume pinot puis m'a dit quelque
chose justement maintenant bon disent
aimer ton quand tu vois quelqu'un
réussit ça t'enlève rien à toile
destivelle dans un milieu surtout quand
même les autres regardent les autres
compacts de tente de centrer à lui le
mot quant à lui monté puis mwana music
chart si on dit qu'on est calculée
littérale littéralement puis de voir
quelqu'un qui va plus c'est des fois
c'est comme ça pourquoi pas motive mais
si ça n'enlève rien à tout quelqu'un qui
dit succès ce soit ça fait du bien mais
alors comment ça m'a fait du bien car il
me dit je
sais une chose c'est aussi ce qui
n'était pas le cas pour le portrait
global dit quand tu vois juste mais dont
le succès de quelqu'un ou quelqu'un à
travers les réseaux sociaux petit on dit
souvent tu as triché mais déjà je le
sais pas qu'est ce qu'un mariage si tu
savais tout portrait global peut-être
que tu es que je te donnerai pas de
place avec la garde
si ça peut aller mais super bien
professionnellement mais
personnellement par
pour plein d'autres variables qui fait
que tu es
ma vie même si sur cet aspect le sap
août et mettons je voudrais que ça et
mieux mais j'ai quand même sur ce saut
ce qui vaut feu king bed peace somme
toute chute est rude en exil notre
personnel non mais l'appât du gain est
fort c'est quand tu es quelque chose tu
veux plus piquante était de l'argentin
veut plus physique athlètes avaient trop
aisée puisque c'est ça qu'il faut se
détacher de tout ceci parce qu'au bout
de la ligne sont ni plus marre d'eux au
monde c'est la distance que je vois est
trop
long mais je les devises ont applaudi
j'essaye de j'essaie de mettre dans des
styles hoffman comme soutenant oui c'est
important je pense que l'on en piste et
un échappatoire c'est peut-être comme ce
que je réussis à faire comme si je dis
ma mère si est en santé à
relativiser car semaine quand même mais
je pense que c'est une bonne façon de
matin de faire comme maman c'est ma vie
pas de casse
dit l'appât du gain pis on à l'appât du
gain juste pour les choses quantifiable
mois de généthon mettons que tu t'y mets
ton d'un nombre de de views temps devant
le st nombre de stream dans veut plus un
nombre de l'argent tendrement le semer
les choses non quantifiable on dirait
que c'est plutôt d'avoir la peau du game
et imed on reprend le concept de bonheur
j'en veux plus ces règles si c'est rare
qu'on s'assoit pas qu'on se pose
vraiment la question à qui et comment
thomas je me rends à plus de bonheur
c'est nous autres mettons
professionnellement mettons pour le pack
à son greenstream souvent pour joueurs
qui et comment construire à plus ou
moins de
succès pour le podcast maintenant de
trucs vraiment quantifiant mais c'est
rare que tu t'assois petit fait bon mais
j'ai pas réel comment je me rends à plus
de bonheur aujourd'hui mangera plus de
temps de qualité avec mes amis
mais c'est vrai que ça doit être parce
qu'on ne peut pas le comté mais par
cette place à quantifier si c'est toi
aussi tu mets ton de jack et loft à un
niveau de ben martin ouais le jouer à
leur niveau de bonheur quand
c'est bon
8 à 89 fichiers
shirts vraiment
quantifiables comme seul bien on a
comme ça tout le monde qui chialent
mettons le plein se rendent compte que
finalement leur niveau de bonheur et
j'ai vraiment plus élevé que quelqu'un
qui est bien violent pas les plats très
bon mais voici qui a le droit tu à lille
c'est pour ça que tu dis qu'est la
perception sein affrété doit et qu'on
voit maintenant de l'extérieur qu'est ce
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
puis tu vois pas aller
derrière les rideaux de hockey c'est
vrai ça je pense qu'il faut arrêter pour
ce que je dis que quand tu vois
quelqu'un qui a un succès dans quelque
chose c'est c'est très cool le thé il
faut arrêter d'essayer de ce qu'on perd
quand même temps
à l'école cela dénote si tu commences ta
ville ptt classe il est classé dans ceux
qui sont bons ou d'instruction moyen
dans ce qu'il dit comment ce même
intervalle isme question de s'écouler
choix que tu fais tu pour aimer ton dire
à qui je fais juste travailler plutôt
repos avant et mon âme
miroir mais j'en serais pas en train de
construire une maison exact attendrait
kaman et aussi
à l'horaire tant que
l'attentât
c'est pourquoi ces cinq top ça c'est
juste un mot
en train de préparer son nid leur
permettre de construire mais tu en es tu
en construction et je suis fini enfin
une auto construction dans le fond
qu'est fac nous autres on est parti en
acheter un terrain des arbres c'est en
battant ce que vous avez acheté la
l'extérieur d'enfants non on a tout fait
de a à z en autoconstruction fax et
comme nous les gestionnaires du projet
puis moi je travaille là bas tout les
jours
mettons de tangage des sous traitants
pour les trucs que tu peux pas faire
mais moelleux comme un entrepreneur
général camille maccione qui l ont fait
en lui un ou deux de ses gammes et on a
monté h pour le montage charpente qui
voit les affamés temps l'excavation tous
les autres trucs sont plus l'église
seule et même si
on n'y rentre on est honnête l'autre ils
s'opposent aux assurances non mais
le panneau il fallait priest mes fils
batum sabra pas un bac effectivement
sauf qu'il faut que ces affaires le
je suis là mais les circuits c'est tout
se sait que c'est un électricien qui est
la norme et même même pas un film
qui sécrètent d'amandine une maison
ouverte le
diplôme est facile de casser de fermer
ou un jab auxerre je mets mon non plus
n'en serait pas là demain mais c'est un
groupe fragile ça fait depuis avril
qu'on est là demain puissent
continuer ce qui est visé l'album ma
maison parce qu'en face c'est vraiment
deux mandats il a je voulais faire les
deux le finalement j'arrête pas de
repousser la création d'un album parce
que c'est difficile d'avoir la tipp fin
d'album commence à être pas tout à fait
le cas toutes les cinq minutes tu penses
à vite oublier sa chute le délaisse le
jeep saleh mais c'est difficile de deux
de ces partis ni le cc comme disent ils
différemment
mais c'est difficile à changer la
constitution la maison s'il ya tellement
d'étapes ses longs cils beaucoup derby
c'est parce que l'album c'est ce qui va
faire que jouer quatre pays ma mère
surtout qu'il ya des attentes et quant à
des attentes moi j'ai des attentes et
fait de mettre ses attentats sur mes
épaules c'est ce qu'ils disent mais j'ai
pas chouette et je disparais dans la vie
c'est où est la maison hantée non non
non c sur un mois
mais
d'abord mons pas trahi quand c'est le
tapis pas l'avoir quand je le peux mais
pour moi cela c'est exactement le bon
équilibre que j'ai besoin d'être dans le
bourg parce qu'on est plus dans le bourg
d'être dans le bois cas
quand je prends un show puis des taches
ou quand je change tout le sait paris
c'est tout le monde le sait mais pour
moi c'est bien important système à
l'euphorie n'est un choc davrinche opitz
va au resto plein de monde dit quand je
retourne chez nous là je n'ai pas pensé
à ce que je fais les victimes se fait
une place de musique
fait fort c'est quand même qu'ils
existent
et il demande s'est jusqu'ici par ya pas
sa pente au dedans maison mais moi si je
touche pour un réalisateur le fait que
j'ai un petit kit la cascade enregistrer
les trucs mais
si j'ai un super bon studio mais tant
pis genre est juste tout mon dictaphone
de 16 c'est vraiment qu'on le fasse à
portée de main quand j'ai une idée je
peux décemment assis dans le bureau et
que logique 12
17 pays ok ça passe quasiment les fans
un peu partout dans ma vie s'est fait
que
je pourrais ne pas m'avoir maintenant
renchérit je le fais parce que je
connais
tu t'es trop ambitieux à l'idée d'avoir
un enfant je me rends pas compte en ce
moment s'est pas concrétisé pour l'homme
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment pas
concrétisées moi je le parc paul chevaux
ma blonde qui ne s'aimait si
je sais pas que tu vas délais avec un
coin
et je planais ben je te disais ma blonde
n'est plus ce genre et ma blonde et
chargé de projet dans la ville de fatick
à charge ce projet
puis moi je suis je m'en rappellerai
remarquons enfin que ça mais quand ça va
arriver je prends cela
comme
l'amour de ma vie mais en ce moment je
sais je sais pas c'est comme si je n'ai
pas dépensé par année pour ma blonde
souvent dit pas si je commets jusqu'à
l'année passée
difficile de cécile parle à quelqu'un
qui n'existe pas qu'existent comme pas
vraiment encore nathalie tisse un drôle
de sa drôle de feeling mais je pense que
quand je vois la vente ou le mettre sur
le le le l'homme
n'ont pas d'enfants mais c'est ça parce
que quand ça va arriver ça va être plus
concret je pense c'est la première fois
de ma vie quelqu'un me demande si j'ai
des enfants ah ouais ouais parce que moi
je me fais jamais demandé je viens tu
viens d'être la première personne mais
j'espère qu'ils me demander ce que
j'ai pas la
même et on l'a juste qu'elle est le
monde le sait que je n'en fais sinon
[Rires]
bichkek
le monde qui compte le plus
c'est quelque chose que mon esprit
d'avant des enfants pour ben ouais c'est
sur cette question le nom et la question
de
c'était une solide question mais je
pense pas
mais d'accord dans le sens que se
posaient la question c'est d'avoir un
enfant faut pas que tu le fasses juste
pour toi tu fasses quand pas quand tu es
prêt parce que je t'ai jamais prêt mais
tous les maîtres un enfant mettons dans
les conditions misérables
mais d'être posée la question c'est un
groupe aussi c'est quand même important
mais si je pense que tu dit elle avec
quand c'est arrivé ça il n'y a pas de
recette c'est un peu comme
[Musique]
mesut arrivé depuis s'était pris comme
c'était prévu une puis ça fait super
longtemps nous qu'on est ensemble qui
ont été rendues le mal en rdc 28,5 ces
jeunes moins
jeunes pour pour 2020 pour 2010 c'est
exact mais
j'avais enfin j'ai
dit c'est que c'est vrai que ça a changé
mais
aujourd'hui la bcge a répondu me
sachant que j
aime aussi ça changeait beaucoup je suis
attaqué sa soif si elle s'est alors
plaint de votre bain
mais
je t'envoie tout le temps que je tais
toi qui disais ça j'ai dit ce que j'ai
vu que ça changeait pas mal ça change et
les dix jours que oui mais comme j'ai
prêché l'apaisement je pense qu il ya
des gens que je veux quelque chose la
précieuse pour une autre affaire que je
pense que c'est juste un moment
personnalité mais comme tu disais si on
n'est jamais vraiment à présent à
s'entendre et je pensais avant que ça
arrive c'est comme
ça paraît tellement gros que ça paraît
tellement puis c'est comme jamais simple
une fois que ça arrive je l'impression
de copies doux de ce que des gens m'ont
dit c'est comme c'est comme look et le
dis comme ça 9 mauricie le tente comme
te voir par khalid et puis qui arrive
l'hôte est vraiment à prendre mais aussi
le dmp la plaine monde qui sont communs
et m il est ça change du tout au tout
s'est fini ta vie'
mais non alors tentez un autre question
de perspective têtu tu es fatigué petit
resto chantant du vin c'est ton problème
c'est pas les activités que ton bébé est
plus petit budget de tamar fin
c'est sûr c'est difficile le but le but
de la vie où est ce que le bébé fait pas
ses nuits plants et boutures 6,9 ses
objectifs mais c'était un petit moment
de la vie dans ta
vie mais ce pourcentage
c'est surtout la plaie l'est le discours
des autres moi qui me faisais commencer
et
puis là j'ai plein de bd autour de moi
puis jeudi par un
métal et supply chain des amis qui comme
disant plus vue puis qu'un enfant de 10
ans je te bats et puis
même chose que toi ticket
kaki camps qui s'affrontent tomber
enceinte j'avais 30 ans comme tout le
monde disait que c'était comme s'ils
n'ont pas un tipi lui il continue à
avoir des projets continuent à forcer à
faire de son fils que design offre une
belle relation avec jose avec tes
couilles il faut l'allumer lyon 10 fois
dans la mesure des intérêts communs
c'est comme si c'est juste rit pas un
type signé bojan depuis que j'ai un
enfant ma vie mais tu te fais demi une
croix sur tout mais mirail il en faut
mais si ce facteur ces cétacés grec
c'est un gros projet mer
non mais si cécile cet opus il était
quand on attend un bon réseau
séparé selon la france hassan
nasrallah enfin je sais comme je trouve
ça l'fun modèles qui vont grandir tout
le monde ensemble des cousins cousines
et puis moi j'ai dit j'ai une cousine
pis tout les amis on rend vain cousins
cousines comme quoi même système à nice
d'abonnement aux familles puis
jaffré ça maintenant
mais oui c'est cool maison moi si tu
vois c'est ça notre forme à savoir le
quatre enfants puis c'est le la petite
le voir je pense que cinq ans on est
donc effectuée c'est comme
pour offrir ce à west ham et enfin vos
pages attendant l'accord design est même
peut-être le fait publier zoo non je
sais métier mettons tout cas ce que moi
c'est ça c'est ça l'enjeu principal dans
mon questionnement si justement de dire
mettons
ce que je l'aï déjà dit ce podcast mais
de dire si j'en veux j'en veux pas 40 un
bon temps pour être capable de le rester
c'est justement le titre on a mis 40 ans
qui parle à son kit de deezer millions
quand même un seuil ont quand même un
gars qui est respectée correct mais
après ça s'est vu capable de jouer que
les enfants seraient capables de botter
le cul de mon abandon puis
[Musique]
est encore là à 100% d'accord je suis
d'accord avec ce long temps j'aime aussi
55 des parts est trop vieux parce que
il y en a que ça fonctionne super bien
ce qu'on a décidé de compter
ces mois maintenant les super riches
avec mon père le gérant du fonds on
parle de de tout le cinéma adulte pilote
dans une relation pis je voudrais
alignement suspects mon
pc
connectés les deux fidèles
les contretemps d'émotion
si le
nom mais lui c'est le premier je parlais
déjà dit la mède occulte auprès des
familles mixtes pourquoi t'es dans la
lune ça s'appelait pourquoi tu es dans
la urnes c'est lui le tc les jeudis le
sommet c'est vraiment qu'on
n'a pas de sens chaque mois c'est ça
fait vraiment rêver
mais c'est parce que c'est tellement un
sujet qui était un moule dans la pente
deroff le
le monde doivent être gêné de parler
aussi parce que c'est vous qui n'ont pas
de nom il ya demande à stx et sans fil
c'est ça ok puis
a même une personne sur deux ne remet
maintenant de madame sur 12 mois est
mouais
j'ai
jamais ton pas là mais j'étais bon
pas dans la vie tout c'était du bon état
de
[Rires]
jugements non plus au départ
un
vrai conflit marre de moi
à 100 mais moi j'en ai t bonds était
vraiment bon ce que tu fais merci mais
j'aimais mieux comprendre mais c'est ce
que je suis la régénération tons pâles
est ce que son nom le sait si bien que
ça
j'ai du temps que mon passé s'ils
quittent on parle des jeux le chômage y
est arrivé commencer mettons les jambes
la discussion le
petit fils de m
godbout je sais pas ouais ah j'ai connu
j'ai même inconnus ton père away ou
c'est pas de la télé ne
pour
satellites connaît pas
connu chez l'indien alors tu as connu et
angie
[Rires]
et moi j'étais d'occupation de campus
sortie d'edel money c'est le monde il
osait comme pas de dire qui avait coûté
au début il savait cette équipe a
vraiment savoir faisait et tout est pour
le
moment je ne répondais rien à perdre et
je faisais allez allez tu pourquoi je
sais pas qui est parfaite en vase il est
si le mot le gars dos d'éléphant man
ccqab là ils sont comme race quand il ya
une dynamique ducks et un instant la
conversation puis ils s'en vont mais j
en ai reçus renouent leurs redoublants
chateaunet pas de casse pillet elle
racontait seul et après aux
délicieuses et des rock stars babin il
n'est qu'ils ont vécu plus que moi
commence comme sorti un coffret que j'ai
pas sur ses acquis - mais quand même je
dis j'ai des amis qui en fait les cons
et des morts depuis jeudi
c'est un bon choix de râpage est cette
fois de rapports les bars étaient sold
out pour les gueux ligue était debout et
cédric pellet adam au bâton et débraillé
peut-être booth si sur le banc même pays
mais
ces phénomènes le ballon mais ça c'est
ces incompréhensions
est ce le fanatisme c'est quelque chose
qui était exempt pour vous
absolument oui moi je peux pas imaginer
si je croiserai je sais pas rapide dans
la rue les gens soient je dirais rien où
je dirais genre j'apprécie
ça qu'ils voulaient non mais sur tout et
je devais
passer en deux
il ya quelque chose avec la tête puis
moi je suis un grand consommateur de
télé réalité moi je trouve ça je trouve
ça si c'est du bonbon la tendance à ce
que moi j'ai besoin d'eux quand j'écoute
des du jeu me divertir je me divertir en
fout le seco jong un piège écouter des
choeurs occupation de toutes les
téléréalités sur netflix d'objecter mon
avis oui mais oui je connais un peu
louis philippe lacroix toujours ouais je
connaissais un peu
puis
puis j'imagine tic la télé réalité
mettant pour la voit maintenant les
artistes leopard
la voie
sacrée des 10 la compétition se disent
compétition par à nintendo et puis parce
que j'ai d'être le package prêche pour
ma paroisse mais la création d'opci nasa
fait des vedettes instantanées si ça
doit être difficile en l2 l'échappée ben
oui c'est sûr
simon finit pas par la rattraper sauf
que
chaque motard takamba ouais c puis je
peux même pas imaginer le temps parce
que provoquent ces mots ce n'est pas une
ascension progressive annoncée vers la
jours la donne
j'avais 200 abonnés sur un style à 200
milles visages en descente rapport genre
trois mois plus tard cinq j'aï mancelle
la mairie qui lie à des madame qui ploie
renvoyant ou à l'épicerie à pleurer
parce que ne pas gagner alors quand et
madame êtes trop investi le fait autre
chose et votre vie ou de votre tante
sympa de bon c'est pas si grave qu'est
ce non c'est ça même et
pourra revenir au fanatisme
moi non plus c'est un concept que je
connais tu que je ne suis pas capable de
concevoir ma tante était des fois tu
vois des images le tir il y avait un
vidéo que circulaient dernièrement
c'était c'est justin bieber qui rentrent
dans son complexe de condos pendant les
camps du monde qu'ils attendent des
petits genre anges à 30 mais n'en
panique le lui regarde fait comme à
écouter georges apprécie vraiment que
vous aimez ce que je suis la chine où
l'oeil c'est ma maison ici l'été c'est
comme si toi après une grosse journée
survient chez vous puis il ya tout cela
qui crie après puis commenté mme rey se
satisfait ta voix et j'en sais pas
comment en même temps
soit peu de vouloir le beurre l'argent
du beurre que de vouloir être à ce
niveau là puis de chialer sur ses fans
qui sont dans la petite fuite a
peut-être ruiné sa foi qui me vis à vis
en soirée depuis elle attend peut-être
donné cinq mille piastres ici et là
c'est sûr que oui mais moi je me suis
bien fait de suivre la nature puis c'est
pas agréable
non mais le lait c'est sûr que non je
suis d'accord avec toi là que c'est
quand tu peux pas tout avoir puis je
trouver des images et des situations
maintenant que des fois c'était comme
state route et puis je mettais mon pied
à terre habitée qu'en guerre au
détriment de perdre sauf stéphane l'hôte
et parce que je veux voir la ligne en ta
vie privée et puis ton travail
ce type tu mets ton je sais pas si tu es
banques et la caisse desjardins
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui suit
ces mois après un show quand je vois
chez nous et qui est mon stock je sais
pas moi c'est hélas pour mener mes
volets où je suis sûr que je suis pas
devenu
la principale le monde sont là souvent
moi j'agis plusieurs gags les fans qui
sont là les shops je trouve ça débile
c'est parce que il voit c'est le même
show mais c'est toujours différent
celui-ci dit c'est un support qui est
incroyable c'est pour moi mais
je contacte comprennent les limites
c'est ça ça c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment important parce que c'est ma
santé bah oui mon équilibre
j'ai envie de décider de ceux ci j'avais
décidé si j'avais du monde chez nous tu
as we pour inviter n'importe qui sans ce
pour moi c'est même important toujours
est il est toujours un faible
pourcentage d'aidé d'été fin août et du
monde en général qui sont décrits plutôt
bonne plutôt bonne plutôt de crise je
suis plutôt du monde justement comment
il y en avait 1 le cam harmonix a fait
la vois que tu es comme qui suivait
était
plusieurs parfums de la voix qui
envoient des messages qui se créent
niveau contre cam années comme avant de
se faire virer de bord et de venise
étaient comme des des menaces puis
c'était comme
je veux je vais faire demain c'est ça
qu'on travaille qu'à la bible c'est
comme si le guerrier il n'est pas besoin
d'être aimée genre puis des fois c'est
sur ces personnalités les points 10
points des fixeurs telle vedette ou un
thé ou à ses pieds c'est comme si ça
fait peur mais moi
surtout si elle demande instamment c'est
comme c'est plus j'aime ton travail tu
as tu as fait la police n'est pas
vendeur pitié cessez le feu la ville de
sibbi breuty
sait comment parler des dents au niveau
1 je changerai pas de place
en fait je n'aurais pas
utile la liberté tisseuse réalise des
cantons de l'est semaine qu'ils louent
une chambre d'hôtel à liège où apple
puis tu étais pas tu peux faire sauter
c'est celui de la liberté t'es pas cap'
une liberté si je pense que la richesse
d'un invité c'est ça c'est la liberté de
faire ce que tu aimes puisque tu veux
puis dans votre tenté de faire sur
piquante et à ce niveau le premier à
solliciter des millions tu t'arrêtes qui
est si tout si performe pas ouvertes et
test de cette pression là qui vient avec
de rester un équilibre
possible mais di lota faire aussi puis
c'est que il y aurait aussi chouette si
justin bieber y mettons là pour regarder
cet exemple lire aussi le choix de deux
comme disparaître la sphère publique
pendant une couple d'années lé séisme
est on vraiment il était pour eux
à vivre sur l'époux réjean parent en
cinq ans pas sortir d'album le monde dit
i passe rappelle tout le monde tu es
coude en un peu les fans tan tan fanny
passera un autre un autre fort effectif
mais il pourrait mais dans le sens que
tu mets ton amy winehouse aurait pu mais
la pression externe aussi des fois tu
étais dans pi c'est comme faut que je
continue pied tape au choix avez vous
écouté les documentaires sur la vie çi
non netflix le écouter seul et s'est
suicidé le final mal mais il voit dans
le documentaire est filmé avec une
caméra
d'ashkan kezman un pilier pas bien et
puis je peux pas je peux pas les leurs
et puis je vais pas faire le show qui
sont gérés comme maintenant vous de
faire la chose sinon ça ne coûte 800 à
1000 de père faut payer tellement elles
sont énormes a fool notre pays je n'ai
juste pas y aller je veux pas y aller
billets non t'as pas le choix c'était
vraiment pas le choix puis film the way
puis finalement elle a 28 ans et où va
aller le
voyez que t'es pas bien mais moi je te
voyais documents et
on le voit les choses filtrer l'eau le
thé dans sa phase qui se pose est que là
pour son bien ti cats faire ces quêtes
du prince s y trompe il y en a plus de
jus le sait le full la peau du game pour
sa propre truc mais c'est l'appât du
gain du monde autocar profit de la
garder quelqu'un sais quoi qui est gogo
continent c'est un numéro aux petites
images parlent de ça par rapport au jeu
on est des numéros l'cie c'est tout le
monde j'ai dit moi je t'ai numéro pour
les jeux pour les gens avec qui je
travaille avec qui et je passe des
semences à la salle est négatif je pense
que les gens autour de moi sont là pour
des bonnes raisons mais quand je vendrai
plus un ticket puis quand je ferai plus
ces gens là ils y auront plus intérêt à
voir avec ce jeu là je le comprends rien
que rien quand certains comme syrien
comme non plus je suis moi je te jeter
un numéro parmi plein d'autres outils
puis
c'est de le comprendre ça met un peu les
choses en perspective ça permet de
mettre ton bien à part quand cette
teinte et parce que tout se sait que tu
es un numéro pour ruth et factuelle
afrique ticad de 10 captieux te dirai
pas de carrière parce que tu as par le
brusque et puis
la partie là mais il faut sauver un
important de
district et qui est des chanteurs ou des
artistes
messi faisait quand même c'est qu'elle
est contraire au pdci pidc petit si
compliqué quand même puis
on est des humains de le faire
comprendre
qu'il y ait quelque chose qui aimait
tant la
colline j'ai pigé pas le brusquer cette
personne là j'ai pas regardé pu me faire
rappeler parce que je privilégie deux
frères se met ça s'entende vraiment
apporter les voix de kadhadi que satan
vraiment un pote une façon de le dire
mais
ça arrive souvent vraiment j'ai vu
passer un post sur instagram c'est déjà
nom et le mot le plus puissant de la
langue
de savoir dire non c'est off mais si ça
fait du bien seppi de aussi être capable
de pop mal recevoir un nom points non ça
me tente pas ce film dans le pot 1 puis
a placé que souvent entre que quand on a
tout dit pourquoi mon expérience c'est
que je suis tout le temps de deux
d'essayer d'être une raison plus garder
ses méthodes mais ton et soutenir
un événement plus ces genres un nom le
team et on demandera à la famille l'a
redit aussi comme non pauvres ce soir
j'ai ma maison lui laisser le pro sen
foule le produit dont les produits non
quelque chose ait un impôt il dit pour
dit non
respect
je trouve ça trop ce qui est kabyle est
respectée toi même ben oui c'est pas
important mais oui pipi puis c'est
encore plus difficile mais ton quand
c'est ton travail tu vois c'est
maintenant vous autres le musée que
l'été et non une guenon endgame et
tapoter tu dis je suis privilégié en
créant de faire ce travail là mais là je
dis non à une geek parce que ta foi king
s'est il faudrait que je fasse un
aller-retour à sept-îles en deux jours
par j'ai un autre guiga blainville le
lendemain le sais que tu sais tu comment
tu veux pas que c'est à black list ce
qui est plate je veux pas être sa black
list mais samedi un
faire cela moi je trouve ça bien sûr
belga acx amos est un combat constant
aussi moi je le suivrai le disent plus
long que j'ai quand même la meilleure
pizza des fautes idiotes et juste c'est
juste une geek de plus plein axe dit oui
c'est plus une autre affaire de plus
plus ferme en berne et si tu te rends
compte que comme tout de même trop
d'afar et puis ça fasse comme en été
comme juste moins ventée du prêt à tout
à fait et puis aussi député puis qu'ils
étaient 1 j'ai pas été moins bon de
temps moins d'énergie de moins le goût
d'être le parrain mais pour toutes ses
impressions ses excès de tout des cas de
cibler des trucs que je t'aime c'est oui
pour les pense que c'est important mais
oui c'est important quand quelque chose
de créatif où nombre de corps d'enfants
de garder mon manque de rien parce que
c'est le cas comme je travaille vraiment
sur quelque chose de éclats qui peut
oublier ces ions qui porte à faux mais
le tu fais ce que tu as vraiment vite
faire on n'hésite plus jamais ces
moments là tu es tout le temps à
réaction qui a comme acquis et j'ai
accompli une chose mais être construit
rien vraiment su plus long terme - fait
que je travaille là dessus
mais toi plus c'est comme s'ils le
projet avec ariane qui comme un projet
de compotée de musique originale c'est
comme vraiment hot fuss genre un projet
de compos comme ce temps ne sommes pas
faire ta a les pieds à faire la tournée
le fait que les jardins des geeks que
met-on si c'était une corpo de genre de
cover peut-être dire et non le tuer
comme l actrice s'est auto proclamé le
séisme et on se tasse et le funk ça me
fait penser ça etc alors j'ai le goût de
toutes les femmes moi si ça mais j'ai
pas besoin d' entre une date à matane
qui doit me cuias les faire encore
possible lui je peux dire ne lui dise
non c'est ça mais faut que tu dises et
moi il faut que je le dise mais des fois
j'ai dit oui à ce avant de dire oui aux
récents avec le
magasin quand j'ai dit oui à ce genre
mon moi j'avais rien quand et comment ce
qui est parfait geek dans le mois
finalement le 25 octobre il
faudrait que
la puissance que je le fasse mais je me
suis engagé mais dites moi j'arrête pas
de maudit bon le jeu fait tout seul de
ces compromis là pour qu'éventuellement
je peux choisir
ouais mais tu choisis jarrige zhari
jamais
tu finis par tout le temps être dans
l'éventuelle mans et je l'avais dans le
présent exaltant dans le camp jour
donner ce petit coup le
fils pour ça que les cadres aient choisi
lol c'est moi je me pose souvent la
question c'est est-ce que ça me tente
est-ce que ça va m'apporter quelque
chose mais si je cadets répondre à ces
deux questions la ssii we must avec
achetés aux cgpi il n'avait trop aux
règles c était ça me tente juges faute
m'apporter quelque chose je veux
apprendre quelque chose puis mettons
sort du pays entre monétaire mais il ya
aussi vu
des fous des fous pas voir là où cacher
quelque chose à mon choix
[Musique]
mais titi 10h15 pour apprendre à deux se
retrouvent au oui après c'est exactement
à ce moment je la
maîtrise est important c'est presque
anglet vix s'est appuyé la décision de
prendre un contre qui se ment paye en
quittant moyens mais que comme qui vaut
la peine
il ça va te permettre de faire tellement
loin d'autres compromis exact ferait bon
sinon autre avalanche justement lui qui
te d'iphones petite avance mais qui paye
en
examen complètement s'user le podcast
qu'ai-je fait que mon avec motion non
pas parce que l'argent fait ça parce
qu'on aime ça puis rencontrer du monde
puis de découvrir des ddc des amis
utilisent
des du milieu
c'est tout se disait je t'écoute
ajustements d'impôt de classe avec les
copines au public et
c'est important que le montant du show
business puisque autant des bandes agi
dans la non mais j'ai des amis depuis
j'ai pas le temps pour les autres c'est
vraiment je suis le sport que je
m'entends pas bien que personne mais si
j'ai pas le temps c'est simple dames 1
puis il y en a et ghana plaint que je
vois plus tiquer que
l'image pour être au goût d'un show
business mettons à la caisse voile mais
souvent je le sent quand même l'agent de
clic clac et
je la sens quand même beaucoup je pense
qu'il ya participé c'est nier cela je
vous aime on connaissait la droite la
gauche de
musique
façon de voir sommet moi je la sens
vraiment beaucoup parce que comme et
deux pieds dans la droite le deal puis
je la sens beaucoup si je sais pas c'est
quoi
qui fait je ne sais pas c'est quoi qui
fait ça s'est su les laits tai chi je
pose et cela maintient la jalousie ou
et/ou des fois c'est plus grand public
c'est ça qui est plus de moyens c'est
quand les chances de la droite la gauche
dans musique le sait c'est sais de quoi
tu parles c'est comme dit qu'ils sont
maintenant ceux qui sont plus dans
l'espèce de systèmes pop
moi
c'est vous comme des suppôts qui
distille parce que des artistes pop qui
sont plus bas
je
n'y a pas de jugement mais tu y mettons
deux frères pim et on marque du prix
vont être considérée comme la droite a
droit c'est moi maintenant ces primes et
ont filé brac klô pelgag
article c'est la gauche c'est ça si on
veut l'attendre mais dit non pitié s'il
le sait le jpy de dix noms mais j'aurais
pu prendre non
poli des leaders d aucuns mais c'est la
personne qui se rend chez la droite à
gauche il ya renoncé c'est comme si
chaud que tout le monde est choqué du
monde où c'est à gauche que sa ghost a
probablement de droite gauche probable
géré par hé oui je trouve ça con parce
qu'au bout de la ligne ont fait long feu
de la musique piti piti y mettons
la gauche un peu tes sont un peu plus
son réseau d'aidé festival pile de trucs
des d'événements plus à droite aussi
piqué dans les publics différents types
oignons puis métro c'est bien expliqué
au final
comme si mais pas d'acquis la jalousie
rentrent en ligne de compte mais je
pense que beaucoup aussi de justice peut
être utilisé chez morgan mettront
l'autriche je regarde la télé c'est sous
le même angle je regarde la radio sur
les mêmes qui passent et puis maintenant
à la radio aussi moi ça fait 80 camille
chansons sont toujours dans le top 5
tigistes pas chanceux mais je comprends
quand même que je regarde les noms les
mains et puis
moi je suis comme love a jugé qu on
t'aime et je comprends qu'il ya des fois
c'est comme qu'il ya d'autres super bon
l'artiste
je pense aussi que les artistes en
guinée de gauche ont aussi leurs
connaissances à la radio qui détermine
les révélations de l'année à l'adisq
c'est pas mal plus ce type d'art soit le
type qui émettront justement tu y vois
cela dit c'est une place trop quel c'est
comme si tu restes étaient séparés
depuis c'est comme quasiment à froid tu
mets le voleur je connais personne c'est
piégeux pour quelqu'un qui comme give a
évité les regarde et je dis bonjour mon
site off est ce que je me trompe s'il ya
quand même un aspect un aspect monétaire
qui peut être difficile c'est parce que
mettons dans les exemples que tu donnes
métier si tu prends la droite j'imagine
que ça parce que moi je le perçois ya
plus d'argent de ce bord là
bas la radio c'est là que cela mette
aussi payant mais la télé la radio
métier les artistes andy méconnu des
guillemets la gauche il convient fac
tcc plus les sources de revenus sont
différents sa dette c'est des artistes
qui vendent des billets au ctpu indiqué
qu'ils jouent aussi c'est peut-être pas
aller aux radios commerciales mais qui
joue sur les radio satellite ce qui
fait que
ça qui est vraiment de la g la place
pour les deux je dirais que c'est
pour ça que c'est une des raisons que
j'ai l'impression que j'ai
j'ai pas je prends un million d'âmes in
la mort parce que moi ça me tente pas de
lien faut aussi qu'ils devraient pas
exister puis aussi parce que jugée
d'autant ben c'est ce que tu dis tantôt
le sien des points qui moi me préoccupe
le plus
en témoin depuis que sortie no deal j'ai
à peine le temps de voir la gamme les
animaux ces gens mes amis amis que je
voyais à toutes les peaux king semaines
avant avant celui après la foire du
passé ma vie a changé un peu mais si tu
as fait rentrer quelqu'un de nouveau
dans sa passion je me dis pourquoi je
veux prendre du temps pour voir cette
personne là alors que j'ai même pas le
temps d'aller voir médium que je voyais
à toutes les semaines métier mais je
trouve qu'un à faire là dedans de
réseautage l'été mettons c'est ça prête
je crois que dimande que c'est un peu
stratégique d'avoir des amis connus pour
leur propre bénéfice et non affaibli ni
fils
puis portail que si je faisais plus de
réseautage arrêt plus d'abord n'était ou
des baisses or avertit puis je le fais
je le fais pas parce que je trouve je
reste je suis tout sauf un quart
activement qui c'est leur façon de
travailler puis si je peux être avec sa
gelée pas le réflexe n'est pas ce
réflexe là mais j'ai l'impression qu'à
un texte un peu stratégique puis
sûrement que j'étais plus impliqué puis
j'allais voir le monde puis je dis aimer
tout le monde puis j'écrivais s'il faut
fermer sa g mais sûrement que le cas je
sortirai quelque chose le tout misé me
cogner les bonnes gens hirscher et remet
à faire qui moi je pourrai jamais
vraiment voir tout ce que guy miclo là
ça me met ce qui amène à consolât men
qui le font le mur séquence est pas
fortuit du monde sont vraiment hâte sont
vraiment mises en
jeu sympa mais quand tu le sens
quelqu'un que dans un événement qui
viennent parler parce que les ils
veulent faire un contact mais que c'est
quelqu'un de plus hautes qui parle il
y en a beaucoup c'est plus qu'en pense
sa gosse puis j'ai l'impression que la
presse à face à autant peut-être que
entre personnes de même
bailly ça marche parce que
d'ici là le dos à un autre mais
comme moi je le sens quand quelqu'un
sait pourquoi est-ce pas de joindre
quelqu'un qui sait pas genuine pixels
ces
puissants gosse je pense qu'on en est
aussi une bonne gagne alors que sa ghost
aux jackets du monde qui est jenson sa
masse ma pauvre et je t'aime et on leur
suivent un travail à ce cargo le plus
marty tellement aussi au festival de
saint paul on faisait sa première partie
avec ariane type on arrive pietro ce
match ne s'est jamais sentie togolais
étaient soit avec moi parce que en
colère parce que je pouvais l'institut
de podcasts ou
ceux qui se battent actuellement ahmed
ben oui c'est en fait j'ai fait un show
de la cgt ma vie
je n'ai pas personnellement mais à
chaque fois je l' ai vu il m'a dit
bonjour à tout le monde ses jumeaux
suscite un modèle mais tombait savaria
pour moi c'est un modèle pour ça pour
s'amuser coup si le puits son écriture
mais c'est ma tante françoise bendit et
l'artiste invité moi mais je veux dire
bonjour ben du mont joie je vais me
présenter je vois pas prendre pour
acquis que je peux je me choisit mon nom
un style je vais pas prendre pour être
certains mais prétend six mois ce point
ça va tu
as une place de bonjour à tout le monde
qu'ils commettaient me freine libye et 8
voix qui qui vraiment
ne dis pas que je fais moi je dis
bonjour monde pourra voir l'argentine
mais je trouve ça important d'aller se
présenter par il fera comme ok go aussi
non seulement c'est vraiment important
gaza 2 3 fois qu'ils m'insultent ceux
qui viennent dans le studio le site
nicole qui ne comptaient sur une canette
notait qu'il fait deux-trois fois qu'il
vient au studio le ppi qui qui rangera
pas le nommer va savourer en papa poule
mais qui rentrent aussi diop sy qui ils
regardent même pas nos techniciennes ils
rendent puis il s'assoit ce divan qui il
fait d'autres choses le tri genre même
pas un regard s'allume rien le syli pour
lui il tentera pas parler d'une annonce
exact pire on a su diop et genre c'est
comme tu es tu peux aller chier aussi
aux
gens c'est ça va pas ça va pas te lever
rien ça va juste rendre tout le monde
plus large
ainsi c'est tout le monde dirait que tu
essaies relation indifféremment mais en
tout cas moi mais la façon que levante
deal avec ce genre d'affaires le
justement comme on parle de tu rentres
sur la web série tout le monde ça en dit
quand même surtout un nom importe le 2
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire le sens du
toit puis comment tu respectes au city
le travail des autres ils amènent les
lags le temps des mots de la chaussure
l'asbl je suis le moins qualif il non
mais sérieusement si tous deux estiment
machin si tout les gens j'en ai mon band
jeu des celi crise de proue mais moi je
suis le moins bon du monde
de loin puis le mois d'expérience ces
foules c'est vrai c'était moyen conçu
depuis 30 ans le médecin qui apprennent
28 tonnes en cinq minutes qui joue mais
non des sharks dans fassbinder la
patente barrette qui donne un show c'est
comme c'est des machines des gardiens
puis moi je dis pas ça parce que je veux
me faire dîner non t'es bon alors
vraiment la poche le jeu le 6 gg pas
prétention puis honnêtement puisque ça
fait c'est que ça me donne je garde pour
m'améliorer a limité mais c'est vrai
faut arrêter de penser ce qui est un
extraordinaire parce qu'on se faisait à
tous les jours qu'on est bon ni nom ni
bull ça c'est ma femme et moi j'aime
bien lui qui le dit lui même ce n'était
pas bon mais c'est le bo de
l'acadie comme coraline certainement un
bon débit qui ont déjà leur église
inversement par exemple pour un
versement
faut pas non plus se fier à la première
impression qu'on se fait de quelqu'un
ici parce que cette personne ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qui a vécu cette journée le
téléthon pour rentrer là c'est sûr que
ça fait trois fois qu'il rentre au
studio qui salue une colle
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive qui comme un
peu dernières minutes tout est oublié
comme ait un peu partout pays triés puis
passe à lui à personne mais lorsqu'on
n'en est pas réglé chacune est dure mais
ma
mais à mon côté une histoire tout
dernièrement d'un artiste qui était
quand même
que vous ayez une mauvaise expérience
avec nico final ils étaient quatre au
smap way aimerait pas le nom mais
on on était à un festival
pileux l'après midi antec la benne puis
en vigueur il ya un sol selon ocz a été
analysé le show pileux on se met à
parler d'un artiste connu le au québec
qui le demandaient les histoires un peu
d'expérience beau fait que l'eau de
trucs de weeds a
déjà le droit chaque fois que j'ai
croisé c'est que le jeu vient j'amène
mon nom se réunit fois je vais jouer
avec panache
puis j'ai décidé moi je viendrai en
parler moi je vois pu aller parler de
sujets ni des deux pilotes est inclus
on pense un petit puis on est on est
vraiment pas un band [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
dans le band mais mes jambes qu'à ce
moment là
on a
un peu et
puis là on arrive aux shoots et qu'on
s'assoit c'était un show attitude à
laitiers plomb pileux on s'assoit qui
quitte à sigean dans l'estrade georges à
un mètre de moi que je puis cech membres
au second tour ait
pilotes tournent qui nous fait un salut
à toi tout est vraiment bonne ligne à
sarrians et tout est un homme vraiment
ce que tu fais pileux ils vont voir des
gars qui dit moi je vois plus parler si
un pilote et un instit drummer le tpir
il sera de son nom rappelle de son nom
et vous voulez vous des bières jon la
grosse maths c'est comme ça se peut pas
que
première partie beauté dans le carmausin
planté l'aï trop
[Rires]
simulation
à quel point genre ça nous a rattrapés
déjà connus
mr méité jamais vu
l'habitation à côté dans le camp
caennais qui ont fait ayant tous un
guichet pour la bière a évoulé de la
bière des enveloppes semaine
ok pas tout lu je
veux jamais c'est vrai quand il faut pas
faut pas y aller au premier degré tout
un no man est un pâté si c'est juste que
c'est quand 55 s'effrite d'hab ça change
rien c'est dans ma vie maintenant
quelqu'un de fait qui vient me dit
bonjour
c'est
exact soutenant l'effort pour ce que ça
faux nom et c'est vraiment ce que je met
les pendules à l'heure il gueule là qui
vient voir jean un manteau le dfe
devrait changer
[Rires]
ce que sur le long terme la technique
mais oui complètement
l'exemple lui même si je connais pas
tant que tu connais pas sa vie métier
pas l'impression que si mi temps le
monde à dos maintenant
je pense que tkt faire que mon titre
avec le monde pourraient être intéressés
aux membres ouvrés par chance à ben arfa
baisse et revient ce que je disais au
début tu n'as pas grand chance de te
tromper si tu restes toi même si tu es
gounou au fond de toile comme seul
humblement le jeu me fait tant d a été
est vraiment pareil quand tu vois en
entrevue à télé que l'eau ou qui a
choqué la vertu mais pour quoi je serais
moi perso j'ai pas de personnage de la
cinquième étant un mois mon nom utile de
vic bourgeois c'est mon nom sur mon
baptiste ans sa
belle peau à gardanne
je ne juge harry piges comme je parle à
personne puis je mets des départs de
contact rouge là qu'il gérait un
personnage assez mais le jeu n'est pas
dans mon corps ouais
ce que tu dis là le puits s'il faut se
re qu avec le début la version même et
tu peux jamais tu sais que je dois faire
la comparaison avec un menteur un
menteur qui m'a pleinement il se perd un
peu dans ses mensonges planning et comme
tout le temps un peu envie est de sentir
mal de dire une affaire qui aurait pas
dû dire et sans crédit
quand tu ma peau jamais qu'as tu es
toi-même tout le temps tu peux pas de
prix pis y'a quelqu'un qui est pas
content avec avec quelque chose je dis
pas content avec toi même touba d'ypres
un autre paquet de biscuits prend un
autre paquet de biscuits exactement
qu'est ce que ça aurait pour toi qu'est
ce qu'on souhaite
des choses des choses qui s'en viennent
cet été la coupe des festivals ou des
festivals qui s'en viennent mais je
souhaitais prendre la 10e mais que ma
petite fille ça et
ça se passe bien - la date à date ça se
passe bien mais c'est quand même
important si oui si je regarde des fois
des parents qui ont des enfants qui
savent au moins bien puisque même le but
je vois le vide ça me rendait
sur c'est la priorité après cela reste à
voir une fois que la santé le reste
aiguë 5,6 millions on attend quand cinq
semi tous cas la
santé
merci
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce père que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup si vous voulez avoir
plus de contenus plus de conversations
sur pétillante que ça se passe ce qui
est sûr p tu es a non seulement on met
tous les podcasts en ligne au moment où
est ce qu'on les tombes donc on a
beaucoup de semaine d'avant sur le pga
mais on fait aussi des encore moins de
filtres qui sont exclusifs aux membres
pétuaud nous est ce que on parle d'homme
n'est que l'émoi de la conversation
combien parce qu'on est un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituel mais le lien vers ce havre
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois de nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fonte